did you know there are more than half a
million cyber security job openings in
the US and millions worldwide I'm Neil
dwani co-director of the advanced cyber
security program at Stanford online
today I'm going to tell you why the
cyber security job market is so hot
right now over the past 17 years we've
seen more than 20,000 data breaches
impacting nearly 2 billion consumer
records this surge in security issues
has sparked unprecedented demand for
cyber Security Professionals in the
United States alone there are over 1
million people currently employed in
cyber security with hundreds of
thousands of jobs still waiting to be
filled that means cyber Security
Professionals are in such short supply
that there's more than a 50% negative
employment rate why is there such a high
demand for cyber Security Professionals
it boils down to the increasing number
of data breaches and cyber crimes the
rapid rise of ransomware attacks and the
ongoing digital transformation of
businesses around the world the
emergence of disruptive Technologies
such as artificial intelligence and
machine learning also plays a role with
all those challenges it's not surprising
that the average wage for an entry-level
information security analyst is of over
$100,000 that's according to the US
Bureau of Labor Statistics if you want
to explore a career in cyber security
and you're wondering where to get
started you should check out Stanford's
Advanced cyber security program where I
teach alongside luminaries Dan Bonet and
John Mitchell no matter where you are on
your cyber security career path if
you're ready to LEAP towards the next
Milestone you're always welcome here at
Stanford online